Hello everyone.
Dr. Adam Reno here.
I'm going to be
talking to you
today about the
pathology of the
auditory and
vestibular system.
This is a very
complex system and
bear with me as
we go through it
as there's a lot
of information.
If you have any
questions or concerns,
please reach out to me
in my email here listed
on the first slide.
Let's get rolling.
Some session objectives.
The first thing
we're going to try
to do is define the
proper terminology
related to dizziness.
Decipher peripheral
and central
vertigo and
what those mean.
We're also
going to discuss
some hearing
loss as well.
So dizziness, what is
it? One of the most
challenging presentations
that our patients
are going to bring
to us is I am dizzy.
It is us as physicians
who are going to
be tasked with the
challenge of trying to
decipher what dizziness
means to them?
Is it dizziness where
the world is spinning
around them? Are they
off balance? When they
walk, are they feeling
as if they're going
to fall down? Is there
intoxication involved
or is it psychiatric?
When they stand from
a sitting position,
are they lightheaded?
In our evaluation of
dizziness, we have to
decide, is this dizziness
dangerous? Is this
something that is
going to need prompt
intervention or is this
something that can be
treated in the office
today are referred to
a specialist for
treatment at a later time.
If it is dangerous,
this can be
related to arrhythmias,
TIAs, strokes.
We also have to decide
whether or not the
vertiginous symptoms
that they're having
or dizziness is
peripheral or central.
This table has
features of peripheral
and central
vertigo and it's a
very quick way
to decide whether
or not it's central
or peripheral.
You can read through
this. The thing that I
want to point out and
have you pay strict
attention to on this
slide is the presence
of nystagmus. If you
think about nystagmus,
often it is present
when there is peripheral
vertigo that is there
and it extinguishes
with fixation. However,
on central vertiginous
symptoms, a lot of
times that doesn't
extinguish and it
continues to persist.
Also, tinnitus or
deafness is often
present with peripheral
symptoms, and
that's usually
absent with central.
On examination, some
of the things we're
going to be doing is
assessing eye movements,
vestibular functioning,
and hearing.
some of the terminology
that we need to go
through are eye movements
itself so if you
think about it some
of the eye movement
terminology it's not
always easy but it's a
good thing to remember
as you're reading
through history of patients
and trying to figure
out exactly what's
going on as far as
examination goes for
example eye pursuit
smoothly following a
moving target poor pursuit
in inaccurate saccades,
that's usually
central pathology,
nystagmus, the involuntary
back and forth movement
of the eyes. Chart
right here that I
really like, I actually
found it when I was
preparing for this lecture
from a previous lecture
that was prepared
for this same topic.
It's just a quick
approach to dizziness.
Let's say you're in the
emergency department
and you have a patient
come in and they're
dizzy. This is a good
quick way to decipher
what that dizziness
is and and what type
of workup will follow.
Clinical case number
one. So we have a 60
-year-old female who's
presenting to your clinic
complaining of
dizziness. Her symptoms
have been worsening
over the past hour and
she does not have recent
trauma to her head.
She states that she
has significant nausea
and is very fearful
that she will fall.
She reports these
symptoms in any position,
whether standing,
sitting, or lying down.
She also recently
recovered from an
upper respiratory
tract infection.
On physical exam,
you see horizontal
nystagmus. She can walk
without assistance.
So the proper
terminology that we
use for her condition
based on this
clinical case
scenario is vertigo.
So there are known
causes of vertigo,
central and
peripheral, like in the
chart several slides
ago, some central
causes of vertigo
are migraine, ******,
tumors,
multiple sclerosis,
drugs, and for
peripheral causes,
there's BPPV,
which is benign
paroxysmal
positional vertigo,
labyrinthitis,
Meniere's disease,
vestibulitis, and
something to remember
again with central
causes of vertigo is
nystagmus does not
extinguish and is not
suppressed with
fixation, whereas in
peripheral vertigo it
normally extinguishes and
is suppressed with
fixation here is a
good diagram for you
to look at again you're
going to be getting
a lot of this in
your anatomy and
neurology lectures however
this diagram is the
vestibular system
and how this works in
some of the pathways
ways. You can see
it's pretty complex.
The peripheral causes
are a little bit
easier to identify
than the central
causes, but I'll let
you go through this.
So the vestibular
system, when we
think about it,
we try to control
eye movement, and
several ways that
we do that is
through fixation,
vestibulo-ocular
reflexes, and
also the
coordination as well.
so vestibular ocular
what you do is you have
a patient look at an
object while turning
their head and have
them fixate on that and
the vestibular balance
what they do is they
look at a tv while
they're running on a
treadmill and they
should be able to do that
fixation itself what
this does is test to
see if the nystagmus
extinguishes what
you do is you give
the patient a focal
point picture on paper
light an object that
is stationary and not
moving the peripheral
nystagmus it will
extinguish on the
central nystagmus this
will not extinguish
vestibular ocular
reflex so this again is
patient fixates on
your fingers you put
them that your finger
in front of their head
their face so they
can look at it they
turn their head from
side to side their eyes
should maintain
fixation on your finger
or on the object with
smooth tracking it's
a lateral failure with
peripheral vertigo
and there's intact
with central vertigo
some things we do is
Romberg testing however
you have to remember
that Romberg
testing may be positive
in both peripheral
and central vertigo
another thing is the
gait should be normal
and peripheral vertigo
again should be
hearing you might hear
the patient might hear
tinnitus or roaring
or there might be
a partial loss of
hearing in peripheral
normally in central
there's usually a total
hearing loss that's
seen some mnemonics
that are used in
practice and these were
again on the previous
lecture some of these
that you'll be using
in the emergency
department in clinic.
One is the attest. This
one's kind of nice.
It's associated symptoms,
timing, triggers,
examination signs, and
testing. The things
we try to do are
to try to decrease
health care costs and
also reduce the amount
of unnecessary
testing on patients.
And this is why this
test was developed.
There's certain steps
used to determine
if acute dizziness is
related to vertigo.
Then we do a hints
exam. A hints exam
you'll actually use
often in the clinic
as well. This is
head impulse testing,
nystagmus, and
test of skew. Once
the diagnosis of
vertigo is given, then
you do this to
decrease neuroimaging.
So clinical case number
two, we have a 75
-year-old female with
a past medical history
of hypertension
who's presenting with
complaint of dizziness.
Symptoms began suddenly
this morning shortly
after waking and has
persisted for several
hours she now comes
to you saying that she
has some associated
nausea her son must
assist her in walking
due to the dizziness
and she also has a
great fear that she
will fall on physical
exam nystagmus is
present and with fixation
it extinguishes the
vestibular ocular
reflex is intact she
has poor stability
poor with eyes open
or closed hearing is
unaffected diagnosis
is actually ******
so next state case
we have a 50 year old
female with completed
dizziness that began
several hours in the
day and is worsened over
the past several hours
she is fearful that she
will fall due to the
symptoms however she
can walk without
assistance she complains
with nausea and nemesis.
Of note, she had an
upper respiratory tract
infection last week.
Her vitals are normal.
On vestibular testing,
she has nystagmus
that's present and
extinguishes with fixation.
Her vestibular ocular
reflex is abnormal.
When her eyes are
closed, her postural
stability is
poor. When her
eyes are open, her
posture stability
is okay and her
hearing is normal.
Diagnosis for this
is vestibulitis.
So what is vestibulitis?
Well most of
the time when
you think about a
vestibulitis attack
in a patient that's
usually abrupt an
onset and it usually
peaks over 24 hours
but it can last
for quite some
time, weeks, months.
It's almost described
as sort of a
Bell's palsy to a
cranial nerve 8.
Treatment for this,
corticosteroids
and antivirals. A
lot of vestibular
symptoms are going
to be treated with
corticosteroids and
antivirals even though
there may not be
some good evidence
in it and some of
it lacks efficacy.
What we try to do
is we try to limit
symptomatic
treatment as this may
prolong the symptoms,
believe it or not.
The brain eventually
extinguishes the
input from cranial
nervate on the
affected side and
vestibulitis resolves.
In clinical case
number four, we have
a 40-year-old female
who's presenting
complaining of
the room spinning.
This started as
she was reaching
for a bowl off
the top shelf.
Symptoms last for
less than a minute
and this area is
also accompanied by
nausea and emesis
no symptoms while
sitting very still
however they do
occur after changing
in her position she
walks into the exam
room unassisted
so first thing we
look at her vitals
there's a reason
why they're called
vitals they are very
vital then we go
and we look at
nystagmus and it is
present on vestibular
testing fixation
extinguishes
the nystagmus.
Vestibular ocular
reflex is normal.
Postural stability
is bad with the eye
closed and okay
with the eyes open.
Hearing is normal.
So in this case, we have
a scenario wherein
we would do what
they call the ***
-Hallpike maneuver,
and we'll get to that
in the next slide
here. On this test,
it is positive.
The *** Hall-Pike
test is positive.
Symptoms last
less than one
minute. No movement,
no symptoms.
So diagnosis for
this is BPPV.
So benign paroxysmal
positional vertigo.
On this right here,
you have to remember
that diagnosis of
history is super
important and as a
matter of fact the
history will give you
the diagnosis for BPPV.
Symptoms again last
less than a minute
and are usually
occur after movement.
Patients commonly
when they get
out of bed in the
morning and turn their
head they'll start
to feel as though
the world is
spinning around them.
You'll have several
patients that come
into your clinic
or in the emergency
department and when
you perform the dick's
Hall Pike maneuver
they feel as though
they're going to fall
off the the gurney or
the exam room table
and in all reality
they're lying there
and there is it's
pretty impossible to
fall off the table while
you are holding them
in that position
this this bppv is
treated with the epley
maneuver so what we
do is we instruct
patients to perform the
maneuver at home pending
safety we want to
make sure they're
safe while they're
doing this at home we
can send them to
vestibular rehabilitation
through wherein
physical therapists are
trained to do this
type of rehabilitation.
You can give them
a first generation
antihistamine like
meclizine and sometimes
this necessitates
a referral to
otolaryngology or
ear, nose, and throat.
This is often caused
by a free floating
otoconia or calcium
carbonate crystal
that has been
dislodged most commonly
involving the posterior
semicircular canal.
So why was the
vestibular ocular reflex
normal during this
test? Well, you think
about it, it involves
the semicircular
canals, and this
test is testing the
vestibular nerve, and
the canals really are
involved in the
vestibular ocular reflex.
dick's Hall Pike
was positive because
it does involve the
semicircular canals.
Keep in mind, though,
that even though
this is positive
for BPPV, this could
also be positive in
vestibulitis as the
nerve cannot carry
accurate information.
Remember that while
the patient will be
happy to undergo
Epley's maneuver as will
help BPPV, they will
not appreciate this
maneuver during and if
it is a vestibulitis.
Here's a picture of
the *** Hall-Pike
maneuver that you'll be
performing in clinic.
You'll have the
patient sit up straight
and have their head
turn 45 degrees
with wide open.
Then you're going to
aid them lying down
and bringing their
head back towards
that same degree.
And you'll actually
stay there for one to
two minutes with the
ear pointed toward the
ground. While in this
position, make sure
you're checking the
patient's eyes. If you
notice dystagmus,
this is a pretty good
indication that that
side of the head is
affected. The side of
the ears, the ear that's
pointed towards the
ground is usually the
affected side of those
semicircular canals.
Clinical case
number five we have
a 58 year old
male presenting
again complaining
of dizziness.
He states that he
has had symptoms
like this in the
past but however
he did not seek
medical attention.
He does have
nausea and vomiting
with a lower roar
in his right ear.
He says that this
has been persistent
for several hours now. He
walks into the
office unassisted.
On vital signs,
you notice that the
pulse is slightly
elevated. However, the
remainder of the vital
signs are normal.
He does have
associated nystagmus.
Vestibular testing,
well, on fixation, his
nystagmus extinguishes.
Vestibular ocular
reflex is abnormal.
For posture stability,
it's poor with
eyes closed and
okay with eyes open.
His hearing is
decreased on the right.
Diagnosis for
this would be
Meniere's disease,
and another name
for this is
endolymphatic hydrops.
Meniere's disease,
you have to
remember, is the
classic triad of three
things. It's the
episodic vertigo,
tinnitus, and hearing
loss. Whenever you
think or hear of those
three things, you
have to think about
Meniere's disease.
This is due to
increased fluid in
the labyrinth system,
the inner ear.
There's also Meniere's
syndrome that's
a little bit
different because it's
the symptom or the
triad of vertigo,
tinnitus, and
hearing loss, but
it's secondary to
other ear disorders.
Normally, when you
see Meniere's disease,
it's going to be
in patients between
20 to 40 years of
age. However, it does
range a little bit
further than this. I've
seen some patients
with Meniere's
disease all the way
into their 50s and 60s.
Unfortunately, with
Meniere's disease,
it does take a
while for them to be
diagnosed. If you think
about it, they come
in, they're having
vertigo, and they're
also having a little
bit of hearing loss.
Some physicians may
mistakenly diagnose
this as BPPV. They'll
be sent to vestibular
rehab. they'll be
started on meclizine, and
their symptoms may
improve, they may not.
Because of this, they
can go through several
rounds of, hey, this
is vertigo associated
with BPPV, until
they finally get the
accurate diagnosis
of Meniere's disease.
Some tests that
you can do are
audiometry,
vestibular testing,
and MRICT of the
temporal bones.
Here's a good picture
of endolymphatic
high drops, and what
it looks like in
normal and an abnormal
vestibular system.
You can see that
there's a lot more fluid
in figure B than
there is in figure A.
This is causing
distortion and distention
of the membranous
and the lymphatic
containing portions of
the labyrinth system.
The differential
diagnosis, and again like
I said this is why it
is very difficult for
patients to be diagnosed
with Meniere's, is
because there's quite
a few things that they
may get diagnosed with
erroneously first.
Acoustic neuromas,
multiple sclerosis,
otosclerosis, diabetes,
thyroid disease,
anemia. There's
autoimmune inner ear
disease. There's
syphilitic endolymphatic
hydrops, BPPVs on
there, TIAs, tumors.
So there's quite a
bit to go through.
Treatment for
Meniere's disease
is actually quite
fascinating.
The first thing, of
course is diet and
lifestyle adjustments.
Try to reduce the amount
of sodium and caffeine
and alcohol in the
patient's diet. Try
to minimize stress
and anxiety. Avoid
environmental allergies.
Less insult to the
ear, the better.
Some patients are even
placed on diuretics.
I'd actually go out
on a limb and say
most patients are
placed on them because
this does help with
their symptoms.
Diuretics include
hydrochlorothiazide,
triamterine, furosemide,
and acetazolamide.
In acute episodic
attacks, some patients
are using clonazepam
and diazepam for this,
and because this
leads to some nausea,
as our clinical case
scenario identified,
anti-emetics
are often used,
such as Zofran
and Phenergan.
Treatment,
you know, well, you can
think about systemic
or intratympanic
glucocorticoids if
they're not responding
to pharmacotherapy.
There's intratypanic
gentamicin that
destroys the hair
cells as well that's
sometimes used.
And if that doesn't
work, then they
go and they do a
labyrinthectomy and a
vestibular anorectomy.
Important points
to know about
the vestibular
system before
we go into the
auditory system
is symptoms last
than one minute.
So symptoms that if
they're less than
one minute, they go
away quickly, but then
they come back with
movement of the
head, usually start
to think about BPPV.
If symptoms last
for hours, think
about Meniere's,
******, or TIA.
They last for days,
then vestibulitis,
mass, or CVA.
Inability to walk,
that's usually central.
Does not extinguish,
usually central.
Vestibular ocular
reflex abnormal is
usually peripheral
vertigo. dick's Hall pie
can be positive and
more than BPPV and
remember history
history history it is so
important listen to
your patients because
they are telling you
the diagnosis now
let's talk about the
auditory system and
some of its basics
here now you're gonna
be getting auditory
pathology and also
anatomy in general
of what the auditory
system looks like this
is just the general
picture from Morse
Clinical Anatomy showing
you that it is complex,
the auditory system,
and there's a lot to
it. We went through
the vestibular system
which is the inner ear
portion that shows
where the cochlea, the
semicircular canals,
that anatomy is at, but
now we're gonna go
through the auditory,
sensory neural, and
conductive hearing loss.
So conductive
hearing loss, there's
some things that
lead to that. Number
one would be
cerumen impaction.
There's also infections
in the external
and internal ear.
There's congenital
causes, otosclerosis,
and trauma that
can all lead to
conductive hearing loss.
Sensual neural is usually
due to congenital again,
medications,
age-related or
presbycusis tumors and
illnesses here is a
table showing you some of
the causes of hearing
loss so when a patient
comes into your clinic
you want to start
at the top say hearing
loss and the first
thing that's there
is history then you
go through an otologic
examination and
whether it's abnormal
or normal and go all the
way through the
algorithm until you find
your diagnosis now
sometimes you might get
to the very end of
the algorithm and the
diagnosis does not fit
the clinical scenario
so they have to go
back through and
refine it here are
some common causes of
hearing loss that are
genetic hereditary hearing
impairment genes all
the way to syndromic
hereditary hearing
impairment genes as
you can see there are
quite a few of them
one thing to keep
in mind that again
that it is a very
complex system and
Some patients will
need to be referred
out to geneticists
or even when
you refer to an
olaryngologist, they
get a geneticist
involved as well.
When you evaluate
hearing loss, the
first goal of evaluation
is to determine
the nature of
hearing impairment,
whether it's sensorineural
or conductive,
the severity of
the impairment,
the anatomy, and the
etiology. You get
a good history, start
the physical exam,
you start external
and go internal
try to avoid irrigation
of the ears during
your exam if
possible because this
can skew your results
and then there's
special testing the
written Weber tests
this is using a 512
Hertz tuning fork
autological
audiological assessments
pneumoscopy is also used
this is interesting as
if when you do pneumoscopy
if the tympanic
membrane is non-mobile
you usually think
that this could be
due to fluid or mass
in the middle air
cavity or if it's also
stiff or sclerotic it
could lead to that as
well hypermobile tm
you think about oscular
chain disruption if
the tm only moves
with negative pressure
then they have a
blocked eustachian tube
you could do temporal
bone ct scans mris you
could do laboratory
analysis as well
some things you do
through blood work would
be glucose checking
for diabetes cbc with
differential anemia
leukemia lymphoma
thyroid studies you do
an rpr looking for
******** syphilitic causes
of hearing loss and
also an a profile
which would check for
autoimmune illnesses
here's a good picture of
the weber and rin test
The Weber test, you
use the tuning fork
towards the forehead
or the top of the
head there, whereas
the rim test, you
actually use towards
the mastoid bone,
and you're testing
for air conduction.
Good table to the
side here. Now,
these tests can get
very confusing for
not only physicians,
but also medical
students. I encourage
you to take a
look at this table
here and decipher
out hair conduction,
bone conduction,
which table
leads to which
diagnosis or which line.
One good thing to
start with is you start
with the Weber test,
and then you do the
RIN. You have to do
both of them together.
Again, here it says
you must use results
from both Weber and
RIN testing. And
this, I'm going to
go through several
examples here to kind
of help solidify this
and answer any
questions that you have.
Because, like, again,
it is confusing.
So, example one,
when you do
Weber testing, if
it lateralizes
to the right,
RIN is positive
bilaterally.
Weber, well, it may
mean conductive hearing
loss on the right or
sensorineural loss
on the left. Whereas,
RIN, air conduction
is greater than bone
conduction on both
sides. so no conductive
hearing loss. This
suggests left-sided
sensorial neural loss.
Another example
would be this.
Weber lateralizes
to the right.
RIN is negative
on the right.
Weber, either conductive
hearing loss on the
right or sensorial
neural loss on the left.
When you do RIN, air
conduction is less than
bone conduction on the
right and it suggests
the right-sided
conductive hearing loss.
Example three would
be Weber has no
lateralization and RIN
is positive bilaterally.
On Weber testing,
this could be either
physiological or
bilateral conductive or
bilateral sensor or
neural hearing loss.
And RIN, where air
conduction is greater
than bone conduction
bilaterally,
normally suggest either
normal or bilateral
equal central
neural hearing loss.
one last thing i
want to touch base on
before we conclude our
lecture is tinnitus
this affects a lot
of people in the u.s
alone in fact about 50
million people in the
u.s have chronic
tinnitus the hard thing
about tinnitus is
it can be subjective
or objective and you
have to get a good
history again from the
patient to determine
the etiology of
tinnitus to them Some of
the theories of this
cause is loss of
cochlear input to the
central auditory system,
loss of suppressive
neural connections.
Some people have
heard of phantom pain.
They're thinking that
may be one of the causes.
And then also
abnormalities in
serotonin levels in
the auditory cortex,
causing aberrant
neural firing.
There are several
etiologies of tinnitus,
one being ototoxicity,
hypertension,
diabetes,
bone disease,
******, tumors,
multiple sclerosis,
medications.
Patients often need
to be referred to ENT
when tinnitus is
pulsatile, unilateral,
or if there's sudden
hearing loss, dizziness,
or facial pain. If
this isn't present,
further testing is
not usually needed.
The treatment for
it is to remove the
offending cause, CBT,
masking, and also
electrical stimulation
of the cochlea.
One of the common
medications that lead
to tinnitus in some
people is aspirin.
So when someone
comes in, they're
having a lot of
ringing in their ears.
Ask them, are you
taking any aspirin?
And a large
majority may be.
Biggest thing with
hearing loss and
pathology thereof
is prevention.
If you can prevent
it, you're going to
be saving your patients
a lot of grief.
Some ways to prevent
it is, number one, if
someone comes in with
an ear infection, prompt
antibiotic therapy
for otitis media, for
example, or use some
tympanostomy tubes when
indicated. Some
children actually have
hearing loss due to
untreated ear infections.
Another thing is
making sure that when
you're using
aminoglycosides that you're
monitoring peak serum
peak and trough levels
and avoiding loud noises
and wearing hearing
protection this is
a big one try to
wear hearing protection
when you're at
concerts using firearms
leaf blowers chainsaws
headphones and so
forth so important
points of the auditory
system would be history
is vastly important
conductive versus
sensorineural hearing
loss weber and rind
testing must be
interpreted together again
they must be interpreted
together you can't
have one without the
other and have an
accurate diagnosis
and then again further
testing or imaging
may be required after
special testing here
are some references
and go ahead
and read through
those and you can
click on some of the
links there that will
take you to where
we pulled some of
this information
and again my contact
information is here
please feel free to
either email texts
or call for exact dates
when i'm in office
if you want to do
a zoom meeting and
we'll go from there
thank you again for
your attention and
again if you have any
questions or concerns
please let me know